[Music]
[Applause]
amantha show you guys have jam-packed it
was such a collecting axe you know let's
talk about Courtney first she really
blew the roof off this place at the
Dolby what was it like to be have a
front-row seat to that magic well I
would say to someone earlier on you know
like I've done these shows a long time
and there have been moments whether it's
Kelly Clarkson Leona Lewis Carrie
Underwood grace van der Waal grace
Camilla and always remember that one
performance where you go that's gonna
make a difference and that was one of
those moments you are the voice of
reason on this show I feel that way I
try right I mean what really goes on
through your head when you hear me help
Eve and her critiques when she disagrees
with you well I suppose it's a good
thing and a bad thing it's like
sometimes you like to shut up but
actually you know what if we all agree I
think it would be boring but what
sometimes what they like and what I like
but we're on a different planet what's
the latest on one direction will we ever
get them back together they're having a
lot of success solar question I do he's
working with me on a show at the moment
in the UK I just think the legacy is too
big not to go back to at one point
plus they have enough songs I didn't
realize how many hits they've had though
they that when they do get back together
it will be a huge event but look they're
all doing their intent they're all being
successful but I have a feeling it will
happen I really do and who's the first
solo record we're gonna get from the
fifth harmony ladies do you think well
Camilla how about no money no monies
next and then Lauren are they going
completely opposite direction than were
used to with with the group with 5h yeah
I mean look like we did with the group
ourselves we never told them what we
think they should do they kind of made
their own decisions Camilla always had
it in her to know where she wanted to be
and she's really doing well shine and
brightest you all right well thank you
Simon
[Music]
[Applause]